[Musique]
aujourd'hui palombes glyphes tél ortola
or selon ces tours la fin c'est long
c'est le roi du gibier
alors commençons par le ballon alors
voilà une super fun oui une magnifique
pardon après évidemment en palombière et
que nous avons plus mais tout de suite
alors même opération
on met les deux ailes dans ma mère et on
attaque pour vous dites mais l'opération
parce qu'en fait au cours de six
éditions vous ai déjà montré cette
technique
quand il s'agissait des perdrix oui
c'est le sourire bien le rachat par les
ags m'a été nous avons plusieurs
palombes l'arrêt sur d'autres déjà plus
mais alors comment peut-on reconnaître
si elles vont êtres tendres ou ferme
alors on prend une palombe qui est plus
mais qu évident et s'éteint lentement
que nous voyons bien en principe falloir
marquer plus mais évident et on touche
cette hausse qui se trouve là celle là
est très vieille et voyait dans ces cas
c'est parce que je les casser mais l'os
est très dur alors ça c'est une vieille
et essayer celle là aussi la gelée les
murs annoncée elle a fait un circuit
plusieurs fois c'est là un vrai retour
est pour ça c'est tout à fait lui hurla
et celle là par contre voilà ça c'est le
jeune mais c'est une affaire de cuisson
aussi parce que cette palombes qui est
vieille et celle là qu'est jeunes celle
là sera aussi bon aure optique celle là
mais il ne faut pas les faire cuire
pareil c'est à dire c'est à dire nous
allons et nous poivrons cette parade
alors on va en faire cuire une rôtie une
vieille et une jeune et vous ferez la
différence
mais quand je vais des salles et les
poivrer joue parce que c'est là les vois
et je vais vous expliquer comment il
faut faire même temps alors vous la
savez vous la poivrée normalement
toujours en tapotant pour que de se
rendre voilà seulement on ne va pas les
laisser cuire autant l'une et l'autre et
nous allons les ans fauchée à la broche
de présenter très bon voilà on va les
laisser à peu près un petit quart
d'heure sans rien sans maître rien on va
les laisser dorer un tout petit peu
pendant que nous
opale on commence à bien retire à la
branche devancé ou peut-être commencer
le salmi bien sûr ma été pourquoi ce que
voulait couper c'est pas le faire de
sales mis le saloum en écopant 4
autrement c'est trop ah oui oui alors il
agresse je prends les choses je vais les
salles et les poivrer je commence à y
mettre la ce est parti alors on va le
laisser dorer bien à découvert a
découvert tous les biens volés c'est
bien ça n'a pas bougé parce que tu es
passé on a été nous avons deux panneaux
qui tourne combien de l'ouvrir sans
remords à la broche nous en avons deux
pilotes red bull encore quand alors
maintenant que j'ai lu scène
on va faire le hachis pour finir le samu
alors jargon ventrèche ail oignon et ça
dès que ça dort et on va le mettre 2,5
me voilà alors comme base de deux achi
c'est suffisant oui nous en servir
alors je vais voir s'il n'est pas
longtemps passé doré pour moi ne sont
pas là c'est parce que voyez à cet
accord saignante
oui
est ce un tableau par toute manière on
avait mis le rappeler on les avait mis à
mijoter dans de la graisse de canard 4
goals à la baise
j'ai toujours votre peau de graisse de
canard et d'une route hervé si vous
pouvez toujours que de la graisse de
canard oui alors maintenant je vais
sortir ses morceaux oui vous allez voir
je vous donnais un plan merci je vais
sortir ses morceaux les remettre sur le
plat vous évoquez une dizaine d'anglais
notre pétrole
pas plus non on va bien sortir même le
gésier ça soit bien bon déjà et alors là
on va mettre nos trashy notre achi qui
se trouve la nation fonds de casseroles
sur fonds de casseroles
voilà et on va faire bien dotées de tous
oui là le fond du juge pendant ce temps
oui maintenant que la fuite
on va brûler du verre faut pas regretter
une bouteille de vin quand on va faire
un bon sens mis en en civet il faut pas
dire bouffe pour la peine pour un lièvre
pour les dépendants me remettre du vin
comme ça c'est pas vrai mais y aurait le
vin meilleur et le sens mieux ailleurs
un vin meilleur le civet les meilleurs
arriver mais on n'a rien on va mettre
dans le civil dont l'ua qui joue dans la
chine on y met tout c'est normal c'est
la mesure oui voilà y'a pas mal il ya
rien dimitra c'est assez abondants quoi
là et alors là là dedans je vais mettre
une branche de terre et de roches
lauriers et on va laisser mijoter 5
minutes
oui sert minutes où seuls rivaux en
belgique la chine
oui après ça va réduire ceci et nous
allons remettre les palombes dans ce set
sauce dans la série le vin brûlé laurier
et le thym
oui nous reprenons n'ont pas l'ombre que
nous allons mettre et on va laisser
mijoter le tout à découvrir non à
couvert à couvert maïté pas que notre
salmis de palombes frissonne oui nous
supposons qu'ils crient déjà pu au moins
une heure à découvert pour les besoins
des images parce qu'en fait ils
devraient ils devraient avoir des verts
et qu'il poursuit pour suivre des
parfums absolument exquis cette cuisson
nous pourrions peut-être tourné près du
feu voir ce qu'il se passe
oui les autres où il tourne la broche
qui tourne à la broche et qui dort très
très très bien et ça va être le moment
de se servir de ce temps ce nom à
brizard alors maintenant
l'opération va et finir de les faire
cuire vous allez voir avec ceux ci qui
est juste à point
je vais souffler dessus pour faire
sortir la cendre ce que vous avez appelé
ainsi qu un communiqué et alors là je
ris m de gras de jambon oui je vais
mettre ceux-ci la voilà
là je vais arroser
voilà pour les besoins avant je n'avais
pas marcher pas m'asseoir
la voilà voyez-vous là et ça aide à
cuire et ça donne un goût absolument
incomparable importe quoi ce serait de
les arroser autres merveilles et vous
alors on remet la pareille et on arrose
vient là est le juste en dessous fayez
regarder la poubelle acoustique
regardez bien nous remettons
l'instrument au chaud et nous avons
peut-être pouvoir attaquer les grives
les grives alors oui oui alors voilà
nous avons quatre grise marei il faut
les plus bien n'est ce pas alors je vais
l'être humain je vais me préparer là
c'est gris qui sont déjà plus même a été
qu'est ce que vous allez leur ferme
je vais les saler et poivrer je me voir
le seul
oui le poivre non une après l'autre
la méthode mais ne suffisant pas de
toujours vous tapotez bien me voyez vous
regardez qu'est ce que je ferais le sur
l'hiver arrive et gelé roulerait presque
dans le ciel pour avoir numa voyez vous
trouverez bon alors là j'en avais déjà
qu'une alors là opération délicate je
prends ma grille 20 et puis comme on est
très gourmand je prends un foie gras
alors je vais couper un morceau de foie
gras fois que je verrai que sa jouerie
nos souhaits mais il faut ce qu'il faut
que je reprends mon cell jeu sale et
toujours pareil je crois vraiment voir
n'avait pas trop vite
alors voilà je sache pas vraiment foie
gras oui je bourre
je parle bien je prends mes gants vous
bourrez travers je dirais moi je bourre
le cul de la grive warwickois gras je le
fasse bien oui et jb un grain
de raisin qui peler et épépiner oui je
le mets dans ma grives et je lui ferme
de derrière comme ceci mais je vais lui
attacher une affaire je m'attacherai
tous ensemble oui je vais faire la même
opération pour tout les grives pour
maïté loi tout ficelé oui le ventre sa
civère foie de canard et avec un beau
deux bougres indre isère alors que nous
faisons alors maintenant et les cuire à
l'emia cuir ah non là alors je voulais
maintenant ces deux petites cocottes
adoré un tout petit peu un aperçu d'un
psy show le savoir sa carrière là on
valait bien les placer de chant va les
mettre pour les faire bien dorées voilà
là on va falloir que ça dort bien le
seuil de 10 un peu juste mais ça va il
faut pas que savez-vous qu'il faut pas
selon lui la formule est sorti et je
mélangeais blanc a tendance à se dire
adro verts 2-1 bleus dont j'aimerais
bien d'autres vertus des ambulances et
le reste on parlera moins d'eux à moi le
bruit éventuellement un sauternes un
cocktail région on va laisser bien on va
il faut laisser réduire ce verbe ma main
de maître avec grain de réserve
on va laisser réduire bien bien des
classes on est bien des glaces et la
castrol qu'elle sera cocotte voilà et
laisser réduire
maïté je crois que la souche hybride
telle est bien à nous maintenant on va y
mettre des graines réserve
voilà parce qu'il faut pas qu'ils soient
des scènes intimes alors ils sont peuls
évidemment était fine et combien de
livres on va remettre l'art tout
nous avons finir de poser nos griffes
dessus
voilà ça va bien le foie gras va bien
finir de donner le goût à la sauce le
foie gras que vous aviez l'intérieur des
rencontres de ses grilles et le vern va
bien arrangé leur normalement il
faudrait ouvrir couvrir et laisser
mijoter 10 minutes pas plus oui dix
minutes et ce sera cuit a été l'émission
n'est pas terminé mais une fois n'est
pas coutume en vie et nous présentons
les plats que vous avez déjà terminée
qu'on a déjà terminé qu'on a déjà
terminé
alors là nous avons les grilles des
grives on réserve et ovins de sauter de
revel sauternes
là nous avons les panneaux annoncent à
la route et à la fuite un grand huit à
la broche cuite à la broche et arrosez
avec le contrat - brûlé aucun bruit
et là nous avons le saint denis de
palans de palanca très bien et vit
maintenant puis maintenant il nous reste
encore un gibier à plumes mais celui là
alors ce qui lui la cedh atemporelle
nous remontons dans les siècles
je ne sais pas si nous sommes autant de
henri iv autant de d'artagnan ou siècle
d'alexandre dumas
en fait je compte se termine on peut
rêver une religion
le roi du gibier un gibier de roi
maïté laur tonnes alors ton à leur dites
moi tout seul
norton ask de choses c'est un petit
enfant merveilleux qui n'est comparable
à rien qui ait un goût supérieur à tous
et que tout le monde ne peut pas se
permettre de marcher parce que c'est car
la foi nous aso très rare 1 on attrape
son mois d'août avec des petites motos
des petites trappes et puis c'est
oiseaux après et mis dans une cage dans
une cage où le don lui dans le du millet
et lee le jour et c'est normal dans une
cage recouverte et la nuit on lui allume
la lumière pour qu'ils mangent sans
arrêt tout âge lui nuit et jour ça dure
peut-être dix quinze jours ça dépend si
l'oiseau un bon appétit s'il marche bien
ça ça les temps voilà comment alors là
on lui ouvre le bec certaine les ouvres
de baic est vite fait avaler de
l'armagnac
voilà et alors là pour il sonde il
s'endort et il est mort une mort à 6 ou
7 numéros seydou sy ne sommes pas
d'autres versions y ait pas malheureux
d'hommes qui voudrait mourir comme ça on
leur ferme beck est autrement on ne
prend comme ça on le sert toc
il s'éteint comme ils ne souffrent pas
et ne sais absolument rien alors comment
allez-vous faire cuire ces tout petits
alors là on reprend voilà on va le salé
c'est simple très très très très simple
on prend en photo la délicatement dans
la main en faisant attention c'est
tellement précieux on met évidemment du
sel toujours pareil tapotant un petit
peu parce qu'il faut qu'il prenne bien
le goût de vous lever naturellement très
vite dissipée canon ou malheur que
pêcher puis de sa personne il ne faut
pas le vide et pour laisser tel que il
n'a rien dans le ventre que de la grèce
alors non le sens des biens n'a ouanna
et on met des poivres saler poivrer
c'est tout on leur pose dans le petit
ramequin et on met ce petit ramequin au
four pendant sept minutes pas plus pas
moins parce que il ne se veut pas nick
rue pour fuir intérieure ni trop cuit
c'est un péché sur sacrilège aussi
mérité la dégustation martelant une
religion dit et cette serviette à de
leur tenant la serviette
pourquoi à la serviette va jouer un
grand rôle dans la dégustation de
l'ortolan et encore il y en a qui sont
bien plus fortement pour les déguster ça
j'en suis sûr parce que moi je ne mange
pas assez souvent quand même mais la
serviette sert à cacher lorsqu'on a
l'ortolan dans la bouche parce qu'on a
la bouche souple 1 degré cet automne
arrêt très gras alors on a tout la grèce
qui dégouline dans la bouche
et puis derrière la serviette on peut se
concentrer davantage on peut se régaler
apprécié déguster vraiment voir ce qu'on
a dans la bouche c'est une chose qu'on
ne peut pas avoir souvent et on veut en
profiter au maximum
voilà alors là je vais commencer à
manger mon art hogan
alors je le prends et c'est tortola îles
et brûlant n'est ce pas alors je le mets
voyez-vous contre la joue il échoue je
ne souffle pas et parce qu'il faut pas
un souffle et pour l'atteindre il en est
là alors voyez je commence déjà à voir
de la grèce faire la figure c'est ça qui
est pas joli
honnêtement je n'ai mendois sachant
nathan le déguster
ces chants et la chose qu'on ne devrait
pas refaire il n'est pas très joli je
commence à le prendre
l us us ces dernières au monde à mercy
trouville déguster ce que je mange moi
d'accord tons chauds c'est bon vous dire
que je vous ai construit à ma place je
vous assure si vous pouviez avoir ce que
moi j'ai je ne suis que rentrent je suis
sûr de berger salat-baroux mais mes
vraies marges
je suis avez vous de tout coeur est avec
vous régalez vous avec moi en même temps
oui
ont coché bon
nous à suivre absolument à tous les
vents ma tête c'est c'est pas comparable
à rien mais je vous assure je dirais
plutôt minière second mini capable maury
pourra mourir d'une coop qu'on se
raconte m
[Musique]